what's going on guys Greg Abbott here
back here right now found some time to
sit down and talk about rough nights
going to do a reaction and review for
the red band trailer but really quick
before I do that I wanted to give a
shout out to a seed and smart campaign
kind of like a GoFundMe in a way but
it's through seed and spark for a short
film called afterparty
this is not a paid product placement the
reason I'm here is because my friend
he's got a really talented dude he
co-wrote the short film committed would
start brandy price about Harley Quinn
and the Joker being a therapy if you pay
attention as all the press and all the
awards and accolades it's still
receiving after like a full year of it
being out it's doing really well he's
got this new short film in the works
called the after-party there's a link to
the description box I'll take you to the
campaign so you could read more up on it
for my little brief teaser for what I
can tell you it's kind of like a mystery
short film somewhat in the vein of like
a Twilight Zone kind of vibe about five
girls sort of explore the life of
addiction ranging from like social media
to drugs and alcohol but they've got
some really interesting takes on it
there's a YouTube video in the
description box it's Colin and the lead
actress they're talking about what this
film is all about they're so close to
reaching all the money they need to
complete the funding campaign it would
really mean a lot of you guys could
donate anything if you can't donate if
you don't want to donate but you want to
show your support it would actually
really help them out a lot if you could
just follow them so if you can't do it
in anything at least give them a good
follow it would mean a lots of them who
mean a lot to me too because I'm really
hoping this gets the full funding it
needs because I really believe in this
project so please go check it out it's
about five young women - it kind of
sounds like the darker version of what
rough night might be about granted I
know rough knife about let's go upon
that period others watch that trailer
links in description box for the after
party
[Music]
again for the minute there could be so
many hot miami-dade we're ready swimmin
Decker ah hi get out here's my now
you're going to be much trouble okay
yeah don't get the features are a lot
because we're all so busy with our
allotted different degrees the work
these days
well since so modders the training potty
clown is three Emily if we can ball just
like a long time yeah I feel that
nothing a stupid [ __ ] crunch into
what [ __ ] cocaine Wow I did a bit of
it
[Music]
that's a painting over territory feel
special why and I will do more and she
called him Sir
so what is it imagine gosh just
interested wondering what okay so
actually we have already 19 15 years in
prison
oh my god
okay weird reaction there that's like oh
well comedies from the big studios is
seem to be getting a little weirder and
weirder seems like a lot of these
comedies are about like Oh normal
situation and then something kind like
three quarters of the way through the
trailer or halfway through it takes a
major flip you know which is like I know
typical for comedy high-concept but it
seems more a pair of these days and a
lot of trailers I'm watching I think I
like snatch with a Amy Schumer right
that's right I think of the house it
will Ferrell and Amy Poehler I do
appreciate that you know it's been many
years since bridesmaids
but ever since bridesmaids we have been
getting a lot more female driven
comedies really showcasing some awesome
female comedic talent out there putting
females and like raunchy comedies that
normally male lead to be a part of I
really have no clue what a bachelorette
party is like for a lot of ladies out
there I'm sure it's fun this whole time
through the trailer just like
something's about to go really wrong so
it just keeps building to something like
that it's feeling like this is kind of
going down to hangover addicts it does
it's not the same plot of a hangover but
it's a little reminiscent of it where a
bunch of people get really [ __ ] up and
then if something goes terribly wrong
when they get [ __ ] I'm but I don't
know if texts like doing it happened to
the stripper of why he dies because
Jillian Bell just [ __ ] it crushes it
breaks his back or neck and firmly
because a lot of these comedies seem to
have the idea I kind of feel like
there's a some guy who's just sitting at
home going would be funny if there was
kind of a heavy chick who jumped a male
stripper then we know killed him by
doing that or something like I can feel
the writer just coming
but if I didn't go this is an idea for
Hollywood and they pitch it I can't
recall off the top of my head of Jillian
Bell and Kate McKinnon doing a movie
together I don't really see too much of
their chemistry in this trailer not
because I'm saying it's not there it's
just not all about them interacting with
each other looking back and what we had
a few years ago and then then seeing
with these two you together I kind of
feel like they could be the next you
know Melissa McCarthy and Kirsten Wiig
not that they're like gone and not
existed anymore people don't like them
anymore I just feel like they could kind
of go in that category I don't want to
say four reasons why but you got to kind
of know why I'm saying that it would be
offensive for me to say that this
trailer came out on International
Women's Day I'm not going to make a joke
about people being overweight
I really can't actually see this film
working I'll get into like what my few
nitpick flaws are about it so far you
know it says from the writers of broad
city and broad city was you know I
haven't seen a lot of broad city but I
can tell you where I've seen a broad
city it's a pretty funny female-driven
comedy for getting this cast of great
talented females together I could
totally see working on a plot that
reminds me of like The Hangover a little
bit of weekend at Bernie's one of my
issues with this this concept is made me
not like I have I don't have anything
against Scarlett Johansson and I made a
video about 12 Johansson words seemed
like I had an issue with her I really
don't and seeing her in the trailer at
first I thought was exciting I'm like we
rarely see Scarlett Johansson I'm like a
straight up comedy I don't really see
why she was cast though she's obviously
the biggest name out of this whole
trailer but I'm not seeing any specific
type of comedic element that Scarlett
Johansson is bringing it seems like
she's just playing the straight man
who's not really cracking jokes and I'm
like okay but come on you got this
chance of Scarlett Johansson to be the
lead in this female-driven comedy I
would love it if she really gets to show
off some awesome comedic chops and she's
not known for doing comedy grant it's
just a trailer so I have no idea if
scholars or Hanson is actually funny in
this or not but I hope that for the next
trip it will always we get another
trailer I'm hoping for the next trailer
that we do get to see a little bit more
of Scarlett Johansson herself actually
being funny is there a Kravitz doesn't
exactly have a reputation for doing
comedies either I mean
I know she was in quite a few episodes
of Californication which to me is not
the most hilarious show but it's still
considered a comedy and she's also been
in a lot of pretty huge films you know
not quite the lead but she still is you
know she's like an x-men first class at
divergent films Mad Max fury road
fantastic beasts and words like she's in
a lot of films and I know she's going to
start as a big little lies which I can't
quite I haven't seen it but I can't
quite up with the comedy or not but she
she's pretty she's pretty funny in this
truth so while I can see people hating
on this trailer I think I have faith
that it will be good Sony tends to turn
out some pretty good comedies so I'll be
there if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can follow me at the greg alba on
instagram and twitter and like i
mentioned at the beginning this video
please donate or if you can't donate at
least follow the after party on seed and
spark calm link in description box thank
you